and he talked really fast and we're
running over to the south tower together
and he says to me not much you and i can
do
i've ordered the fifth alarm for the
south tower
but it's going to take them a long time
to get there
do your best to be careful
and when he finished saying that to me a
woman
came out kind of out of nowhere an
employee of the port authority who owned
the buildings and she was screaming
there are people trapped there are
people trapped in the elevator over here
over here
and chief burns gives me the go
gives me the nod he went to the command
post i followed the lady
and she took me around to where the
um elevator lobby was in the south tower
and she took me to one elevator car
specifically
and the door the hoist way doors were
open so you could see into the shaft
but the elevator car had not come down
all the way so just at the top of
the opening there was maybe six or seven
or eight inches
where you could see into the bottom of
the elevator car
and all these people were trapped you
could see all their feet
and you could i specifically remember
the men's
suit jackets in in dress shirts
because they were reaching kind of under
the
top of the elevator opening right trying
to pull the car down it's hard to
describe but i hope people can
understand what i'm saying they needed
to increase that six or seven or eight
inches to 12 or 15 or 24 inches so that
they could slide out of that opening
right now they couldn't slide out they
were trapped
what i didn't know until later was that
car that elevator car free fell 70
floors
because the plane united 175 snapped the
cable
when it crashed into the building so
these people
had taken a 70 story
free fall in an elevator car thinking
they were dead
jesus but the elevator car
uh the brakes you know they designed
elevator
assemblies for this kind of thing
so the emergency brakes grabbed onto it
and stopped it before it hit the
concrete pit
so the elevator emergency brakes worked
the way they were supposed to
slow the elevator down so they didn't
have some like abrupt impact
yeah they would have been dead right for
sure there's a concrete
pit right below it you know but it works
you know
it worked the way it was supposed to and
it saved all their lives
but now those brakes are locked onto
that car
and you're not moving nobody's moving
that car that's that's
like that's it they're stuck there
so they're screaming
because of that but also because the
elevator pit
right below them was full of jet fuel
that was on fire
and they were right above it so right in
front of my eyes
they were getting burned they had taken
this free fall
for 70 floors to be saved by the brakes
but now being burned
so that burn burning to death is one of
the worst things that could ever happen
to you
out of all the worst things right were
the i mean what were the flames with the
flames like coming out from everywhere
all over the round all around the
elevator yeah below it so it's it's like
it's like being sitting on a barbecue
right
you know it's just it's a terrible
terrible thing
and here's big brave
hero fireman tim completely useless
because at that moment i was not a
fireman i worked for the mayor
so i didn't have my gear on i didn't
have my fire protective gear on
i didn't have my tools and equipment i
had nothing
and i'm looking at them wondering
how the heck am i going to help these
poor people
we used a couple of fire extinguishers
to try and put the fire out but it was a
jet fuel fire you don't put that out
easily
and i turned to my right just to see if
i could see
something to help and when i turned
i hit something and i looked over and it
was a bumblebee
and i looked up and it was my friend
mike lynch
uh i had worked with in times square in
1990 91.
mike lynch was another big guy he was
6'4 also
and he worked he was a brand new fireman
back then in 1990 91
and uh one of the most competent young
guys
uh who terry my best friend
and i knew in fact mike was being
groomed to go to rescue one to work for
terry
because terry thought that much of him
that terry that michael could
work with the elite of rescue one and
all of a sudden here's
michael lynch from latter four standing
next to me
and he puts his hand on my shoulder
because he saw what i saw
and he puts his hand on my shoulder and
he says timmy i got it
three words i got it
between firemen who knew each other
who had worked together that meant that
he had
the training the experience
the tools and equipment because he was
wearing his all his firemen gear and he
brought a whole fire truck of tools and
equipment with him
and the intestinal fortitude to save the
lives of those people
he was the real fireman that those poor
people needed
in that moment
in that moment over my radio
urgent urgent urgent confirmed by the
fbi
third plane incoming it's ours impact in
a minute imminent
take cover take cover get in the
stairwells
i said mike i gotta go you got this
because i had to go to the command post
and mike waved to me and i waved to mike
and that's the last time i saw
firefighter mike lynch from latter four
going back to the elevator scene now
mike took
the spreaders from that
equipment to try to open that gap
exactly exactly try to spread that gap
and we know that he saved the lives of
three women
because three women identify the guy
with the red four in his helmet as the
guy that got them out
uh before the whole building comes down
and kills all the rest of them including
mike
and i told them i told the guys that
were searching there in the south tower
and the weeks afterwards
you're going to find mike firefighter
mike lynch from ladder 4
with the hearst tool with the people in
the elevator
that's where he was and that's exactly
how they found them a couple months
later
um in the subsequent weeks
um it became necessary without going too
much into it
it became necessary for me to go out to
mike's home to speak with his widow
denise
uh and i went out there i drove out
there i sat down in their living room
she had two little boys uh a
two-year-old and a six month
six month old and i sat down and i said
there are some rumors out there about
latter four that are
false i want you to know
that you heard it from me that i was
with your husband
in his last moments of his life
and he died an american hero
selflessly staying in harm's way
to save the lives of people he did not
know
the oath we take as firefighters and
police officers
and military right
when we all join up we all go like this
and we say in that moment
for my career i am willing
to give my life for people i don't know
we don't know if you'll ever fulfill
that we don't know if you'll ever be
called to fulfill
that but in that moment you've already
taken that oath
and in this moment firefighter mike
lynch
fulfilled it i told his widow denise
that when mike said timmy i got it he
put his
hand on my shoulder timmy i got it in
front of that elevator
he may as well have had the angel wings
coming out of his back
because he was the angel sent to save
the lives of those
innocent human beings
you